Speaker 1: There is a very interesting article in
Salon by Amanda marcotte about what we are about
to see Republicans do, Republicans that who are
right as we speak coming to power, taking control
of the House and I guess selecting a speaker of
the House, although it's been harder to actually
get that done. The article is called The GOP Is
About To Go Wild With Phony Biden Investigations.
The media must not take the bait. Republicans know
how to manipulate the both sides impulse of the
press. Hunter Biden's laptop is not a story,
writes Amanda marcotte. This is an important
admonishment that I hope is being made in
corporate media newsrooms around the country,
although I fear that it is not. The both sides
narrative is a toxic form of false equivalence
that has unfortunately become really common
in corporate media. And there's a couple of
reasons why, and this is the idea that
all political viewpoints are equally
valid and deserve to be heard regardless
of their factual basis, regardless of their
connection to reality. It's intellectually
lazy. It undermines critical thinking,
it undermines rational discourse. And those are
elements that are essential to a functioning
democracy. Why does corporate media do this? Why
does corporate media have to use one example,
one person who says, here is the climate science
and one person who just denies it, it's 5050 on
your screen. I mean, look, I see this talking head
saying, here's the climate science and I see this
talking head saying, you can't believe any of
that stuff. They're getting 5050 representation,
even though in the empirical community, one side
has more than 99% agreement of the scientific
community behind them. Why does corporate media
do that? There's two main reasons. Number one,
they do it because they want
to avoid being called biased
to some degree. They say, well, listen, it's
controversial. So let's represent these two
things, 50, 50, even if in reality they are
not 5050. That's one reason. The other is for
ratings. It's much more interesting to do these
debates where you actually foment the belief
in things for which there is no factual basis.
When the media fall for this trap, they give
credibility to lies and misinformation, and they
perpetuate those ideas. They perpetuate also the
idea that there's not really an objective truth.
Listen, let's have a debate as to what the tax
rate should be. Okay. Well, that's a debate. There
are moral questions, economic questions, fairness
questions, governance question. Fine. Let's have
a debate as to whether climate change is real.
Totally different thing, irresponsible. And by
the way, I'm fine with discussions among people
who disagree about the climate science. I think
that that's fine. The problem is that corporate
media that does 39 minutes of content per hour
or less, the rest is commercials and hosts four
minute debates where half the debate is a climate
science denier. That's a different thing that
we're talking about. And it's especially dangerous
in the current political climate where we see the
rise in authoritarianism, we see a decline
in trust in institutions. It's important for
the media to hold politicians accountable. It's
important for the media to hold public figures and
so-called experts accountable for their words
and their actions. But you've got to do so in
a way that at least somewhat aligns with reality.
It doesn't mean you give equal weight and time to
baseless conspiracy theories and propaganda. And
that's where we get to Joe Biden. The Biden Crime
Family Photo Essential. I accidentally hit the
truth central button because I'm so so wound up.
What we what we have to see here is a recognition
that the Hunter Biden conspiracy theory is the
prototypical example of how the both sides
narrative can end up just being so destructive.
It's been thoroughly debunked. It's been fact
checked. They insist on baseless elements of
Hunter Biden's background. At some point, the
media has a responsibility to report what the
facts are, not to promote baseless conspiracy
theories, to give equal weight to lies and
propaganda, to host false debates, which is what
they are at the end of the day. And to the extent
that Republicans are going to be obsessing for two
years about impeach Biden for these crimes, those
crimes, Hunter Biden, this, that, the other thing.
If corporate media is going to cover that, they
should just be clear. There's no credible evidence
to support the things that people like Marjorie
Taylor GREENE want to investigate about Joe and
Hunter Biden. Will they do it? Probably not.